it's crazy
is is
um
like this
it's such a special experience
um
about the laptops
you can use this
seriously
is
focus right here
um
oh
medications
is
it's like
um
is
okay
this is
[Music]
thank you great to see you
thank you great to see you all
because
the stage
yes
one
that's right
now
sorry
thank you very much
so
foreign
hey
so
happy friday ryan karen's got some
sunglasses on everybody's ready for the
weekend uh
okay i have a couple of items for all of
you at the top uh last week we launched
the supply chain disruption
task force to monitor engage and act on
current and emerging supply chain
disruptions
and bottlenecks this afternoon the white
house is hosting a convening of the
supply chain disruptions task force
with secretary of commerce gina raimondo
secretary of housing and urban
development
marcia fudge director of the national
economic council brian diese
domestic policy advisor susan rice
council of economic advisors
chair cecilia rouse and groups
representing the full range
of the home building supply chain from
bloggers and
contractors labor leaders realtors and
affordable housing advocates
at this convening uh these
administration officials and key
stakeholders
will discuss strategies to address
short-term supply chain disruptions
in the home building sector and how they
can work together
to address them i also wanted to note
that yesterday senior white house
officials led by susan rice and julie
rodriguez
launched the community violence
intervention collaborative
announced by the president on june 23rd
as part of his comprehensive plan
to reduce gun crime uh the community
violence intervention intervention is an
evidence-based approach
that has been shown to reduce violence
by as much as 60 percent
cvi prevents gun violence and crime in
communities around the country before it
happens by intervening
in disputes early and connecting
potential potential perpetrators
and victims with services and support to
divert them
to divert them away from crime it's an
approach that's been embraced by an
increasing number of law enforcement
leaders nationally as well as by mayors
of both parties
and cities around america so this will
be an ongoing
initiative i also want to give you an
update i noted earlier this week
that there have been 2 million people
who now have access to affordable health
care thanks to
the reopening of the um
the enrollment special enrollment period
uh yesterday we launched a summer sprint
coverage campaign
leveraging robust paid media increased
community outreach and more to get
americans signed up this president is
urging americans who need health
insurance to visit
healthcare.gov or to call 1-800-318-2596
they would prefer to enroll today we'll
keep talking about this quite a bit
until august 15th which is the end of
the timeline
i also have promised you that i would
give you updates on
interesting initiatives we're taking to
reach people
meet people where they are as it relates
to getting vaccinated so on saturday
nascar will host the get vaccinated 200.
they'll have vaccines on site and will
be encouraging vaccinations this is the
type of whole of country
approach that is reaching people in
convenient locations with messengers
they trust
finally a quick week ahead on monday the
president and first lady will welcome
their majesty as king abdullah ii and
queen ronnie of jordan
and his royal highness crown prince
hussein to the white house
their majesty's visit will highlight the
enduring and strategic partnership
between
the united states and jordan a key
security partner
and ally of the united states it will be
an opportunity to discuss
many challenges facing the middle east
and showcase jordan's leadership role
in promoting peace and stability in the
region on monday the president will also
deliver remarks on the economic recovery
and the progress made under his
administration taking the country from
60 000 new jobs per month
to 600 000 new jobs per month and from
one percent of americans vaccinated to
more than two-thirds of adults
with at least one shot he'll explain why
his rescue plan has helped us get here
and will continue supporting americans
throughout the year and why we need
the infrastructure agreement and his
built-back better plan
to sustain that growth in years to come
while keeping inflation in check for the
long term
on tuesday the president will hold his
second cabinet meeting of his
administration
his first in the cabinet room get
excited everyone uh
and uh he looks forward to that and on
wednesday the president will travel to
cincinnati ohio
to participate in a cnn town hall
with that alex why don't you kick us off
and then one on the um um can you talk a
little bit this is happening
yeah you made it happen can you talk a
little bit more about the hong kong
business advisory and related sanctions
and what triggered those
um and also there have been reports that
wendy sherman may attack visit
on to the end of her asia visit can you
talk about what her goal might be with
something like that and does this mean
that we're moving closer to
i know last month there was talk about
potential fighting president xi
uh summit are we really closer to that
sure well first as the president said
yesterday the situation in hong kong
is continuing to deteriorate and we
continue to see beijing
assault hong kong's autonomy and
democratic institutions we've seen
authorities use the national security
law
to make politically motivated arrests
and we've seen a general deterioration
of fundamental freedoms which were
guaranteed by an international agreement
so that's why the united states we
announced steps we're taking today to
promote accountability and transparency
on the accountability front the state
department announced earlier today
seven officials who were sanctioned for
their actions threatening the peace
stability
security and autonomy of hong kong on
the transparency front
today the us government issued a
business advisory as you noted alex i
just want to give the full context
for hong kong which is intended to
inform businesses
and highlight the growing risk for those
operating in hong kong
the bottom line is that businesses
should be aware that the risks face in
mainland china are now increasingly
present in hong kong
and as the president said uh last month
of course we will not waver in our
support for hong kong
and all those who stand up for the basic
freedoms but as businesses are making
decisions and obviously they're making
decisions themselves
we want them to be aware of the use of
data
accessing of data inappropriately of the
restriction of information
and they should be aware of that
happening on
in hong kong as well as in mainland
china
got it uh in terms of wendy sherman's
trip
we uh i don't have an update on travel
we of course have been and continue to
explore
opportunities to engage with prc
officials
we've been clear we will engage in
conversations at the appropriate level
uh when there's an opportunity for them
to be substantive and
hopefully consequential so i don't have
an update on intended
travel obviously they're quite adept
over there at the state department of
adding things as needed
and as it relates to plans for the
president as we've said he will look for
opportunities to engage
with president xi going forward he
we don't have any particular plans at
this moment so no decisions have been
made
but we'll continue to evaluate what's
appropriate and what would be
constructive in the relationship moving
forward
there are reports that it could be
financed in part by
tariffs on carbon heavy imports which
could end up rising
uh picking prices on goods for american
candidates it
is the white house open to that and
would that be a concern similar to
the gas tax there are ongoing
discussions
about the final components of course as
we
look to and i know you are all eager to
see uh bill language and legislative
language and of course
having discussions about the pay fors
are part of that uh the president's
bottom lines have not changed
about uh the fact that that any pay fors
cannot raise taxes on individuals making
less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year and anything that would
impact that would not be something he
would support
go ahead um
those of us old enough to go back to the
future those who are younger i don't
know what they think of
but um
given the fact that discussions are
ongoing if the discussions are still
ongoing come wednesday does the
president believe
that the senate should vote um should
take the procedural vote to move forward
if there's no field text or deal in hand
well i think uh
one uh leader schumer of course will be
running point
and leading effort to determine and
making the determination about
uh the timeline the process and the
sequencing of votes
in the senate and we certainly work
closely with him uh
and uh and but we certainly trust his
his uh
path that he is mapping out for the
legislative process
uh we have several days i would note
before monday uh
for more information to become available
we'll see what is known
uh i will note that um the president
is quite familiar with the roller
coaster and ups and downs of legislating
having spent 36 years there and even
having had some successes over the last
few months and working with legislators
uh he we had a productive meeting
members of our team had a constructive
productive meeting
yesterday and i'd also note that there
are a number of republicans and
democrats who feel the same
in terms of the path forward senator
portman said we're going to get it done
and that we're time we're in at this
point you went through kind of the top
line details of this yesterday but can
you elaborate a little bit on
the facebook administration to facebook
flagging disinformation and there's also
some reporting
uh that we've had facebook maybe hasn't
been as proactive as the white house
would like it to be in response to some
of the flag so
the process of how flagging works and
then whether facebook has been amenable
to those requests
sure well i would say first it shouldn't
come as any surprise that we're in
regular touch with social media
platforms just like we're in regular
touch with all of you
and your media outlets about uh areas
where
we have concern uh information that
might be useful
information that may or may not be
interesting to your viewers you all make
decisions just like the social media
platforms
make decisions even though they're a
private sector company and different but
just as an example
so we are regularly making sure social
media platforms are aware of the latest
narratives
dangerous to public health that we and
many other americans
seeing are seeing across all of social
and traditional media
and we work to engage with them to
better understand the enforcement of
social
media platform policies so let me give
you an example just to illustrate it a
little bit
uh the false narrative that remains
active out there about covid19 vaccines
causing infertility something we've seen
out there
flowing on the internet quite a bit in
other places as well
which has been disproven time and time
again
this is troubling uh but a persistent
narrative that we
and many have seen and we want to know
that the social media platforms are
taking steps
to address it that is inaccurate false
information
if you were a parent you would look at
that information
and that would naturally raise concerns
but it's inaccurate
and that is an example of the kind of
information that we are flagging or
raising
has facebook been as proactive as the
white house would like in terms of
its response to what specs well i think
as i noted
yesterday phil there is more there are
more steps
uh that uh everyone can take and i would
just note again
this is a responsibility of officials
speaking
of course on behalf of the government
it's a responsibility of members of the
media it's the responsibility of
uh citizens and civic leaders and people
who are trusted voices and communities
around the country that has a broad
definition social media platforms is one
of them
and as we know it is also there are also
areas where a lot of people get news
and information sometimes those are
accurate
news items uh reported by some of your
outlets or
accurate information shared by neighbor
sometimes there is information that is
not it is hard to discriminate as we
know this is not a new issue
but it is an issue that is impacting
people's lives so
a couple of the steps that we have um
you know that could be constructive for
the public health
of the country are providing
for for facebook or other platforms to
measure and publicly share the impact of
misinformation on their platform
and the audience it's reaching uh also
with the public with all of you
um to create robust enforcement
strategies that bridge their properties
and provide transparency about rules you
shouldn't be banned from one platform
and not others uh if you affor uh
providing misinformation out there
taking faster
action against harmful posts as you all
know information travels quite quickly
if it's up there for days and days and
days when people see it
you know there's it's hard to put that
back in a box and of course promoting
quality information algorithms i don't
know how they work
but they all do know how they work so
those are some of the steps that we
think could be constructive for public
health for public information
for public and you know the right of the
public to know
go ahead just to quickly follow up on
the facebook aspect of this you said
yesterday that
12 people were producing 65 of the
misinformation on
vaccines on social media platforms do
you have a sense of who those people are
are they bad actors like russia and
facebook responded
yesterday after the press briefing they
say that they've removed 18 million
pieces of coven misinformation
uh they've connected more than two
billion people to reliable information
so
does the white house find that
sufficient clearly not
because we're talking about additional
steps that should be taken
and frankly information that uh media
organizations could determine could
decide whether you're going to report on
or not i'm not talking just about the
misinformation storyline
i'm talking about uh these individuals
i'm talking about
um you know how pr how prevalent the
spreading of this information is the
public has a right to know that's the
point
that we're making and we're dealing with
a life or death issue here and so
everybody has a role to play and making
sure there's accurate information
obviously those are steps they have
taken they're a private sector company
they're going to make decisions about
additional steps they can take it's
clear there are more
that can be taken and i'll actually i'm
kind of just on the foreign government
piece because i think that's an
important uh point or important
interesting question
um the state department's global
engagement center has found that
russia and china have promoted their own
vaccines through messaging
that undermines western origin vaccine
depend
development programs so uh you know that
is more than just competition about
vaccines the risk and impact there is
that
this if information magnifies uh
you know the risk of potential side
effects associated with western vaccines
this is what they're what what the
information some of this misinformation
is doing
and misleads the public by falsely
alleging that
mrna vaccines are untested and thus
risky even though many of them are
approved
and have gone through the gold standard
of the fda approval
process so the prc for example has also
suggested that the united states
hoards covit 19 treatments and prevents
other countries from acquiring vaccines
despite evidence to the contrary
but certainly pushing information out
there that these tested approved
vaccines
are ineffective and unhelpful a lot of
people on these platforms
they're not discriminating as you all
know between the source of the
information
and that is damaging as well so we've
seen that trend on afghanistan thank you
as we look at the withdrawal in
afghanistan what is your assessment of
the taliban's advancements
um we heard from the president he said
the likelihood that there was going to
be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely
does the administration still believe
that the afghan government can maintain
control of the region
i think that what the president was
conveying is that it is not inevitable
and we have provided a range of a great
deal of support
supplies training we're continuing to do
that we will continue to provide
security assistance
uh in the coming months to the afghan
national forces uh
but it is up to them to determine are
they going to unite
as a country are they going to stand up
and fight
against the taliban and that is it's
really in their
hands at this it will be in their hands
moving forward so
his point is that it is not inevitable
there has been no intelligence
assessment that is said
it is inevitable even as they we are
assessing what the consequences could be
go ahead thanks ben when you talk about
misinformation it seems like one of the
best ways to counteract some of the
vaccine misinformation that's out there
would be for the fda to fully authorize
these vaccines for the full weight of
government approval behind the vaccines
but now we're hearing
that may not happen until january 2022
or even later is the president
comfortable with that timeline
the president's comfortable with
scientists and uh data experts moving on
the timeline that that
they see is appropriate and i don't know
that we know that to be factually true
to that that to be the main driver
i'm not even seeing data to suggest that
that the main driver of it is
if it's formally approved or not a lot
of the misinformation that is traveling
out there is about
the consequences and the impact of the
vaccine it's not always tied to or
necessarily tied to whether it's been
formally approved or not
obviously that may give medical experts
or others
some greater level of confidence we will
see but the president's going to leave
it to the fda to determine the timeline
so the president doesn't have
any concerns about the length of time
that the approval process
takes currently at the fda he's going to
allow them to move
at the pace of science okay and then i
want to ask you about the new reporting
about uh
joint chiefs chairman general milley who
had apparently some very serious
national security concerns just before
president biden took office did he brief
then president-elect biden about his
fears about a strike on iran or about
the possibility of an attempted coup
i'm not going to speak to private
national security consequence or
conversations i should say obviously the
president had many conversations with
general
uh millie miller uh during his time
in his role uh and most of those or none
of those do we read out i will say that
he strongly respects general miller as
you know he had the opportunity to sit
down with him on wednesday
thank him for his outstanding leadership
of the resolute support mission
including overseeing the vast majority
of our drawdown from afghanistan
which is a particular vulnerable period
during a particularly vulnerable period
for our troops
does the president think we came to a
possible war with iran
or an attempted coup here at home i'm
just not going to speak to intelligence
matters from here
go ahead thanks jen first on cobot
origins is the white house worried that
china continues stonewalling the world
health organization
investigators and now is saying things
like they think maybe kobe 19 got into
china through frozen
food we are certainly remain or continue
to be concerned
peter about misinformation coming from
voices in china about certainly the
origins their lack of participation in
the process their lack of
willingness to provide data and
information to the world health
organization
as you know we are undergoing our own uh
process here our 90-day review here
but certainly uh the chinese providing
information being in
a participant in the process would aid
the effort and then speaking of
misinformation and the announcement from
yesterday
for how long has the administration been
spying
on people's facebook profiles looking
for vaccine
misinformation well that was quite a
loaded and inaccurate question
um which i would refute well peter first
of all
as you know we're we're in a regular
touch with with a range of media outlets
as as let me finish as we are
as we are in regular touch with social
media platforms
this is publicly uh open information
people sharing information
online just as you are all reporting
information on your news stations
okay so these 12 people who you have on
a list
12 individuals do they know that
somebody at the surgeon general's office
is going through their profile i'm happy
to get you the citation of where that
comes from there's no secret list
i will tell you that these are people
who are sharing information
on public platforms on facebook
information that is traveling
is inaccurate our biggest concern here
and i frankly think it should be
your biggest concern is the number of
people who are dying around the country
because they're getting misinformation
that is leading them to not take a
vaccine young people
old people kids children this is all
being a lot of them are being impacted
by misinformation
though i think for a lot of people on
facebook is that now this is
big brother watching you they're more
concerned about that than people dying
across the country because of a
pandemic where misinformation is
traveling on social media platforms
that feels unlikely to me if you have
the data to back that up i'm happy to
discuss it about things that are on
facebook i looked this morning
uh there are videos of dr falchi from
2020 before anybody had a vaccine and he
is out there saying there's no reason to
be walking around
with a mask so is the administration
going to contact facebook and ask them
to take that down
well first i think what dr fauci has
said himself who's been quite public
out there is that science evolves
information evolves
and we make that available in a public
way to
the american people exactly i i have
never seen
any data to suggest that uh that the
vaccines cause infertility
that is information that is
irresponsibly traveling okay
okay about the science of about the
science evolving facebook used to post
i used to block people from posting that
coven may have originated for a lab that
is something this president now admits
is a possibility
so is there any concern that things you
are trying to
block or have taken down might someday
turn out to be
we don't take anything down we don't
block anything
facebook and any private sector company
makes decisions
about what information should be on
their platform our point
is that there is information that is
leading to people not taking the vaccine
and people are dying as a result and we
have a responsibility as a public health
matter to raise that issue
the responsibility we all have the
government media
platforms public messengers to give
accurate information
go ahead the 12
individuals that are on that separate
sites not from the white house i don't
have the source in front of me but we've
read it as well can you
give us a sense of who those individuals
are as was asked before and what
specifically
you've given a tough message to the
social platforms that they should do
more social media platforms
what from this podium is the message to
those individuals the 12 of them
who are responsible for 65 of the
misinformation that's out there
the message is the same message as it is
to every
person out there who has a platform
whether that is an elected official
or that is a person who is a civic
leader
the vaccines are safe they are effective
if people take them
they will save their life in many cases
and so
our message to everyone who's sharing
this information is that
your the steps you're taking are
irresponsible they could lead to
people's
uh people getting very sick and people
ultimately losing their lives
why don't we all participate in a
process that will help provide accurate
information out there
is the white house participating in any
direct contact with these individuals
given the impact they're having through
any
avenue to try to say knock it off no and
i'm happy to get you guys the
the data on where we got that
information where the public yes the
publicly available data will get you the
citation is what i mean let me ask you
if i can then about some of the other
numbers as they relate to coven right
now obviously uh
due to the delta variants covet cases
are up sharply right now
testing is down right now how concerned
is the white house
that this variant covet in general is
much more widespread
than we're aware of publicly at this
time you know it's a great question i
don't want to speak out of turn here
because it's really a question for the
health and medical experts and how
they're tracking that and how concerned
they are
we certainly know on transmissibility
and based on the cdc data that
the delta variant is the is it is
impacting the majority of people who are
getting sick with covid now we also know
that
99.5 of people who are in the hospital
are people who are unvaccinated and
people who are dying of covid
unvaccinated
the data is very clear as dr wolenski
said on an earlier
uh an earlier briefing today this is
really becoming a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
and that means getting vaccinated you
can save yourself is there anything
the white house is doing differently we
saw the president proudly in
philadelphia
shaking hands with a lot of folks when
he was there for his voting rights
speech earlier this week we saw
something similar last week when he was
in illinois
given the reporting about some
breakthrough cases right now are there
any things that the white house is doing
differently
as it relates to your own staffing or
the president's handling of his sort of
activities due to those new numbers no
we are vaccinated the present's
vaccinated
we are all vaccinated breakthrough cases
are not something that you that you were
we get we have it still have a testing
protocol and process in place for white
house staff so that that has continued
and for those individuals that he would
be shaking hands with there's not any
basically shaking hands is good if
you're vaccinating uh we have we
abide by public health guidelines as it
relates to the president's engagements
and if
public health guidelines changed which
i'm not predicting we would continue to
abide by them
go ahead i'll come to you next april
on the meeting that you're having with
the housing industry today at the white
house uh
how concerned is the white house about
the supply shortage in the industry
leading to inflationary pressures is
that a
serious concern is that why this meeting
is being held the meeting is being held
as part of our effort to connect
suppliers
who have said in the past to our
economic experts
they don't always have the opportunity
to talk to one another we know
from because of the pandemic there have
been supply shortages and areas that
have led to a reduction of new building
and construction which has led to also
an increase in housing prices because
there are just certainly just not enough
houses on the market so that's what it's
related to
is an opportunity to discuss with them
bring them all together in a room
and it's part of our multi-faceted
effort to
address issues in the supply chain and
one on cuba
the president uh did say yesterday that
the united states is trying to
uh reinstate internet access for uh
cubans and i was wondering if uh if the
white house or the administration
uh has reached out to u.s tech companies
i mean the googles of the world
to help with that effort so it would
really be led um that effort would
really be led by the state department
and other appropriate entities within
the federal government as the president
noted yesterday
returning internet access to cuba would
certainly be something we'd love to be a
part of uh it is
we're looking at what our capacities and
what our
tools are we have uh in terms of more
specific the
specifics the state department would be
the best entity to talk to about it can
you go ahead
oh sorry april go ahead and i'll come to
you um voting rights now
tuesday president uh biden said he
called for
activists to act on the issue of voting
rights
what did he mean by that was that to
escalate it higher
to republicans so that they can change
their minds and
maybe stop using the filibuster
and also what does he think about what
happened yesterday with the arrest
of the congresswoman and nine other
black women
who peacefully walked through the senate
halls in the heart building
chanting and singing and were arrested
not taken to the holding cell
holding the area but taken to a jail
cell
well april first he what he meant by
uh speaking out or having your voice
heard or the range of ways he said it is
that
in order to make change happen in
washington
often you need to create a grasp roots
movement that's led by the american
people
and it's not just about whether we can
whether the
minds of 10 republicans can be changed
directly by a
phone call from a president it often
requires activism engagement
a vocal uh opposition or or excitement
from uh from members of the public
that's gonna take a lot of different
forms right and formats
it can take letter writing phone calling
uh there's
pro peaceful protesting there are a
range of mechanisms for that and
certainly
our country even in recent years has a
great history of that
uh and these uh uh these uh members who
were
some of them were members i should say
one member um who was
arrested yesterday uh they were
peacefully protesting
i would note that uh uh our support for
the right to peacefully protest
and to voice support for moving forward
on voting rights
uh is exemplified by the fact that the
vice president is currently meeting
right now
with a number of members they're here a
number of them are at the white house
discussing exactly this issue because we
want to be standing by their side in
this effort
so they um some of the civil rights
leaders are here as you said
but last week when the civil rights
leaders were here they said this is the
summer of action
they're expecting more protests reverend
barber says he's gonna have a bunch of
women out
um on monday there's gonna be more
protests on wednesday
more arrests they're anticipating
arrests to bring more attention to this
does the white house support that civil
disobedience for arrests
we support the right to peacefully
protest we support
uh people having their voices heard and
certainly there are a few issues that
are more fundamental to
our rights in this country than the
right to vote go ahead thank you
i'll come to you right next if that's
okay go ahead uh clarifying
the follow-up sure uh on afghanistan
yesterday you said
that uh 10 000 applicants
uh excuse me twenty thousand afghans
have applied
um and that about half of that have
completed necessary paperwork
to move forward in the process just
let's move forward in the process does
that mean ten thousand sib applicants
will be evacuated no that's not what it
means it just means that they're in a
later stage of the process
so it just it was just giving an update
kind of on the pure share and as i said
yesterday
that doesn't include family members that
includes individual interpreters
or translators so it just means they're
farther
forward in the process there's another
step in the process which is
security vetting which would need to be
completed before any individual is
relocated to a base in the united states
individuals could be relocated to third
uh countries
before that process is completed so it
was just an update kind of on where
people stand
in the process to take a step back to
why did the administration
wait until june 24th to commit to the
evacuation
what why not have this be one of the
early steps right when the president
announced this
in april i believe while american troops
are still on the ground
i mean announcing this just days before
the combat mission is essentially
over would seem to to complicate the
mission well
i would say first uh there's always
ongoing discussions
both with our partners in the region and
others before an announcement is made
and sometimes it requires a process
to get to the point where you are making
an announcement about
the relocation of uh thousands of
individuals
out of a country second i would say
we've also committed to
not only relocating these individuals
in advance of our men and women service
men and women
coming out of afghanistan we have quite
a capable department of defense and
diplomatic apparatus in afghanistan and
around the world
to implement this but we've also
committed to continuing this process
from there and having a diplomatic
presence
on the ground from there so this is not
a process that will end
but this is a process that we announced
at a time when a final decision
was made based on a range of factors
internally have any other countries
outside of u.s territories
uh given the us commitment the
administration commitment that they will
house
uh siv applicants while they're still
having their applications we're having a
range of discussions as you know uh
when we're at the point where we have uh
final uh agreements
uh and we don't and we're we're
confident that it won't impact the
security of individuals who are being
relocated we'll share all of that
information with you as well
i don't have any updates to provide to
you today go ahead oh i'm sorry go ahead
yes so what can africa expect
from this administration in terms of its
engagement
in helping solving some problems that we
are having right now for example angola
is fighting corruption
and also can we expect some revision
in the sanctions in zimbabwe
i don't have any update for you on
considerations around sanctions i'd
point you to the department of treasury
or the department of state on that
we of course will remain deeply engaged
uh with our african partners on a range
of issues whether it's corruption
or facing and fighting the covet
pandemic
uh or uh economic opportunity and
development uh
and i would note that uh we have a
number of leaders
high up in the government including our
u.n ambassador
linda thomas greenfield who has spent
quite a bit of time
working with leaders in the region and
playing a front and center role for the
united states government
but in terms of specifics on zimbabwe or
angola i would point to the state
department
regarding this information do you have
any data that shows
that children have been affected by
misinformation
and how do you see we
educate children about these issues
because i'm working on
a show that will inform little kids
about many different things
and i'm also concerned about
misinformation so in your research about
this information
is there any misinformation affecting
children
as well that's a really interesting
question i don't have any data at my
fingertips i will reiterate that
of course children are not eligible
under the age of 12 yet for vaccines in
the united states
and uh health and uh health infra or
decisions about
the health of children as a parent
myself would obviously be made by the
parents
um in in coordination with doctors but i
would say there's no question
that when there's information the
example i gave earlier about
the impact on fertility uh of which is
inaccurate and false which is still
traveling around
uh the internet if you're a parent that
would give you pause
if you think that is accurate
information uh about your child
and about your child getting vaccinated
so that's an example i don't have data
but just an example that could be
applicable go ahead yeah thank you jim
uh i have a question about the
direct funding of states and cities from
the american rescue plan
for 350 billion uh let's talk to the
treasury department about 200 billion
has gone out
um and several cities and states have
been quick to
to allocate that money but there's other
mayors and governors who have talked to
who have spent
very little of that funding so far in
some cases none of it
either because of battles with their
state legislatures over the funds
their late budget cycles lengthy public
input processes
or they're they're something doing
better than expected revenue-wise and so
there hasn't been a sense of urgency for
them
and so my questions are you know does it
concern the white house that some places
haven't gotten their money out
quicker and does the white house have a
message to governors and mayors
that don't have any plans yet to spend
their funds and finally
does that signal the situation i've
described if not of some
some folks not spending their money
quickly does that signal that the money
wasn't
urgently needed well i would say first
the uh
in the ensuring that states and local
governments had the funding they needed
to keep employees on the job to keep
cops on the beat to rehire them in many
cases
was a priority when we were negotiating
the american rescue plan
for a range of elected officials
including mayors and governors across
the country for good reason
it sounds like there's some different
case-by-case scenarios that
have made it more challenging in certain
governments and localities
we have an entire team here and at the
treasury department that works closely
with
them it may be most constructive for you
to talk directly to them either jean
sperling or jacob liebenloft about
different issues that are having
happening in different cities or states
once that money is being well
spent and that uh you know they're going
to get it out to address
what you identified as a is a problem
for cities
absolutely and there is of course a
range of options that cities
and localities have for using the
funding and we wanted to provide that
flexibility on purpose because
one city or town or state does not
fit all one size doesn't fit all i
should say for cities towns and
localities
that was important that flexibility
there are still restrictions on how it
can be used and how it's implemented
we obviously also which is not what
you're asking but i'm just going to
reiterate
take waste fraud and abuse incredibly
seriously the president is
uh sheriff joe and his heart and forever
um so
uh that's something we watch uh but uh i
would i would say it might be
constructive for you to talk to them
directly about the implementation piece
and i'm happy to connect you directly go
ahead karen
vaccination rates are actually going up
in the five states that have the highest
rates right now what does the white
house think is driving that and what is
being done there that the administration
could apply
to other hot spots yeah karen um and i
know this was announced on
our covet briefing for those of you who
were not on it in the past
week the five states with the highest
case rates arkansas florida louisiana
missouri
and nevada had a significantly higher
rate of people getting newly vaccinated
compared to the national average which
we obviously see is a good
sign and in the last 10 days 5 million
shots have been
administered and millions got their
first shots
it's hard to pinpoint one particular
piece but what i would say is that
we're continuing to work to apply the
lessons we've learned over the last few
months
the biggest issue far and away is access
and that means something different
in different communities in some
communities it is
ensuring that people know uh that they
can take time off of work
uh because of the the kind of jobs
they're working
in some communities it is meeting people
where they are in places of worship
mobile clinics which is something we're
doing a lot in rural communities
walk-up pharmacy appointments at their
workplace or in schools
we are also continuing to
fund support uh trusted messengers
because we have seen time and time again
that it is more effective and
many of you have covered political
campaigns this is not a surprise to
most people have covered political
campaigns trusted messengers
are people in communities they are
neighbors they are civic leaders they
are clergy
they're not always the president of the
united sometimes it is but
uh and they are medical experts and so
we are continuing to support those
efforts
uh we think that all of those have been
effective um there's
still more work to be done but certainly
that's encouraging those trends that
we've seen
that things have to get worse in these
hot spots before they get better that
fear is driving the vaccination rate how
concerning is that to the white house
well that is not our preference uh you
know that is why we have made uh
vaccines so readily available for months
now
that's why we have employed these
tactics for months now
making vaccines readily available
accessible working with
trusted messengers and partners we also
though have seen
in some communities where local news
stations are covering
uh young people unfortunately who are
getting sick
some being put on ventilators i don't
know i can't tell you from data what
impact that is having but we are seeing
in areas where there are lower
vaccination rates uh some
some positive signs over the last week
we'll see if that continues go ahead
thank you
i have uh two code questions and one
voting rights question okay
make it fast um on covet um
you and dr wolinski have used this this
phrase the pandemic of the unvaccinated
and
i am wondering if any part of that is
the administration
distancing itself from responsibility
for the pandemic
um because you've been trying to get
people vaccinated or if
um or if it's a scare tactic
well i would say first the data speaks
for itself which
99.5 percent of people who are in
hospitals because of covid are
unvaccinated
what it is our responsibility to do is
provide
accurate public health information to
the public
it is also our responsibility to stay at
it
and continue to communicate to fund
programs to support trusted messengers
to get out into local communities to use
what we see as
creative partnerships to meet people
where they are
we haven't stopped that we haven't
halted it we haven't even slowed it down
but certainly from the public health
experts et cetera and i repeated what dr
wolinski said because she is of course a
doctor and i am not
uh it is important for people to
understand that the vaccine is safe
it will keep it will protect them uh and
it is as simple as that and sometimes
olivia rodrigo
was this sort of a one-off thing i know
that you had worked with other
celebrities before and you announced the
nascar thing but
is there more work with young
celebrities or
country stars or anything else that's
coming or was that more of
part of the month of action that's
behind us wouldn't it be great if this
was the cue for like blake shelton and
gwen stefani to come out from
that would be awesome i wish that was
happening today uh it is it is a
part of an ongoing effort and we want to
partner uh with uh trusted voices and
individuals in
communities many of whom you will never
have heard of and they may have five
twitter followers if they're
on twitter which they probably are not
if they're not on the coast and not
liberal but
um we will also use uh we'll also work
with celebrities
and we will work we will also work with
um individuals like olivia rodrigo i
know i said this the other day
but obviously she's a very well-known
pop star she's 18 years old
she doesn't have to use her time to do
this she is speaking to a broad swath of
an audience
that i bet you is not watching the white
house briefing and is probably not
watching the president of the united
states and we recognize that
we need to meet people where they are
including as we use partnerships and
media and engage with media as well go
ahead i'm very sorry to have one more
but on voting rights the president on
tuesday called on congress to pass
federal voting legislation he spoke
about the urgency of it
the question is what comes next is he
going to travel around the country and
make this case
is he going to go up to the hill and and
have meetings
specifically about voting rights i know
that he's
talked about you know activists need to
build the grassroots but some activists
are sort of pushing back on that idea
saying like we can't always be the ones
that are asked to do the work
he's not saying to do it alone he's
saying i will be with you but he's also
saying
that grassroots activism is what is
going to move
and change the country for the better
that's always been the case
throughout history in terms of what he
will say and do i don't have any
scheduling announcements for you at this
point in time
but he has said this would be a cause of
his presidency that means he will use
his time
use the plot his platform to make sure
he's speaking about
elevating it engaging in it and as you
know the vice president
this will be a top priority for her she
will be front and center for the
administration on this issue
moving forward go ahead thanks jen i was
just given the wednesday
timeline that senator schumer has laid
out what will the president be doing
over the weekend to help things move
along will he be making calls all
weekend
and then what's his response as well to
republicans who are concerned that
tougher enforcement uh in the irs won't
be enough to generate enough revenue
well first i would say the president has
proposed a number of ways to pay for
these proposals
uh that have have been out there in the
public and has been a part of these
ongoing
discussions uh which are continuing uh
and those proposals he has a number of
proposals out there that will more than
cover
the cost of this uh this infrastructure
agreement
uh that do not violate what the
republicans have said is their red line
in this case which is the 2017
tax cuts uh regardless of his point of
view on that we'll take that on in the
buildback better uh reconciliation
package uh
in terms of what he will be doing the
president is ready
willing able looking forward to playing
any constructive role he can play
and getting these pieces of legislation
across the finish line will that mean
phone calls
sure will it mean bringing more people
to the white house it probably will but
i don't have anything to
kind of lay out for you here separately
has the intelligence community
attributed
to cassaya uh ransomware attacked the
russian government
and has uh it been concluded that the
rnc was indeed hacked
well first i would say the rnc put out a
statement when that news came out
saying it was a third party that had
their information accessed
not the rnc a vendor of the rncs i'm not
aware of the information they're
changing i would point you to them
on that the fbi is of course doing an
investigation and in touch with them
i don't think they've put out any new
information since then
in terms of the cassaya attack we have
pointed to the fact that
that our evil has
many cyber experts have have attributed
have assessed
their engagement here uh we have not
attributed uh the russian government's
involvement
um in this case it's an ongoing uh an
ongoing review but
we have not we don't have any new
information on that front go ahead
and i mean i'm curious if the uptick in
the delta variant if that
is playing any part in where the
president is leaning in terms of
extending that federal mass policy and
public transportation i know it's set to
expire in september is he
leaning towards extending that even more
we've seen some health officials say
that they want to extend it
even now well he's going to lean into
the advice of his health and medical
experts and teams
on any steps that need to be taken to
keep the american people safe
given we're talking about september i
know that feels like a short period
of time away it is actually some time
away but he'll continue to
receive updates from them uh on a range
of issues as it relates to kovid i'm
sure they'll discuss this and their
views
and on that same note he said yesterday
that he's going to take into
consideration
uh some factors before uh he talks about
what will happen with the european
travel ban is that going to play
a part into that with the delta variant
coming up
well as it relates to uh the travel ban
uh we certainly
know we've made important progress on
the pandemic we'll continue to put
public health
first the president all decisions about
reopening international travel will be
guided by our public health and medical
experts there are ongoing
working groups that are having these
discussions to keep open lines
of communication uh he will be receiving
an update uh soon i believe uh if not
today then in the coming days
on where things stand but uh we must be
vigilant uh particularly about the
spread of variance we'll reopen
when health and medical experts expect
it is safe to do so go ahead
uh does the president plan to reappoint
the fed term into another term
i have no announcements or
pronouncements on the federal reserve
chair or any other personnel to convey
jesus
i don't have a timeline to project i
know that there's a timeline for when
the
uh when his uh his services will need to
be reviewed or determined
um go ahead let me just get around let
me just get around go ahead
i had a question about if i made the
generation
opposition neither of them will be in
washington next week and she said she
would meet
high ranking officials i was wondering
whether you had details about that
i don't with me let us get it to you
after the briefing members of the
national security team or the state
department was she more specific or just
people from the us government
she just said uh high-ranking officials
okay let us get you more information
after the briefing
uh reese who's our special guest uh from
tell us where you're from who's
not been have you been here before i've
never been here okay
welcome welcome to thank the
um so i my question is really just about
we've kind of touched on the
um vaccination rates in like rural
country rural counties
especially in oklahoma we're seeing a
significant rise in covenant cases
um there's very specific plans that the
administration has to help um
increase vaccination rates in these
rural counties that
really these people don't have any
intentions of even getting the vaccine
well we've talked about this a little
bit but what we're doing
in rural communities is employing a
number of the tactics
that we've seen uh work around the
country so
we also we know access is a huge issue
in rural communities uh because
people may not live near a pharmacy uh
they may not know
still where to get a vaccine we
certainly understand that so part of
what we're trying to do is deploy and
make sure we're expediting our
deployment
of mobile vaccine units to rural
communities to bring the vaccine to
people
where they are and where they live to
make it as easy as possible
and so this work is going to continue
person-to-person community to
community we're also working with a
range of trusted partners
locally you may people may not have
heard of those are also very important
trusted voices
but also groups like the national rural
health association
to make sure that we're deploying
effective tactics that they think will
work
to get vaccines out to communities and
meet people
where they are we've talked about it a
little bit here and obviously these
states have a combination of
rural and city communities but there are
states states like arkansas
louisiana missouri where there are large
rural communities where we have seen an
uptick which is a
in terms of vaccine getting vaccinated
higher than the
national average that's a positive sign
we'll look at that and apply those
tactics
other places in oklahoma to make sure
we're continuing to go
community by community and meet people
where they are go ahead
up on that i know the administration has
said they're not interested in any sort
of federal mandate
do you encourage though employers to
require the vaccine for their employees
or
state and local i know there's a little
bit of discussion about local
governments the white house encouraging
others to require the vaccine of their
employees other residents
we know that some employers hospitals
health systems
colleges universities uh local uh
leaders uh have chosen to take this step
and we expect
others to do so as well uh but our role
we're playing from here
is continuing to go community by
community person to person
making sure we are meeting people where
they are to get the vaccine out we
believe that
local communities entities organizations
are going to make decisions
about what they need to do to keep their
community safe and what about
for federal workers or members of the
military
i don't have anything new to report on
that
go ahead question the justice department
inspector general's report of the fbi
handling the nasser case
that's the latest embarrassment in a
string of embarrassments for the fbi
this summer
does the president have complete
confidence in christopher wray
and what is the administration's message
to people who see this bungling
and want to know if the fbi is up to
task with ransomware domestic terrorism
and other threats
well first i would i would point you all
to the expansive
statement that was put out by the fbi in
response to the inspector general's
report second yes he has confidence in
christopher wray
third as it relates to ransomware uh
this is an across
government interagency effort one that
we have not seen done in the past i
gave a little bit of an update and a
readout of it yesterday
where we're tapping into all of the
resources and expertise across the
federal government
the fbi has been a key partner in that
as have another number of entities in
our national security team
uh who can play a role in fighting
against ransomware
go ahead oh good and then we'll go we'll
i'm sorry go ahead we'll get you doing
back go ahead
go ahead go ahead sorry okay so uh so
you haven't talked about apec this was a
decision that the president had no one's
asked about it now's the moment
and so there seems to be a convergence
between president biden president xi and
also president putin
in terms of making and sharing and
distributing vaccines
my question is the mechanism of it we
know that apec supports the trips waiver
as does
president biden was there pressure from
apec member countries
to have the u.s put more diplomatic
pressures on wto countries
to pass the patent waivers well
first i would say the president's view
continues to be exactly as you laid it
out there this is a long going
ongoing process uh and ambassador tai is
our lead representative
in these discussions and negotiations uh
the apex summit for any of you who
watched parts of it
uh was virtual and was uh individuals
delivering sets of remarks it wasn't an
interactive opportunity i would say and
president xi
actually delivered pre-recorded remarks
so he wasn't even there
participating in person and just to
follow up on the help um
health and virtually live i should say
yes information do you consider claims
by some in the conservative circles that
uh ira mexican am i pronouncing that
right as a promising treatment for covet
as
misinformation i know that the fda has
weighed in on this i believe in march
but uh i just wanted the
to leave this position on the drug
information that's inaccurate
we consider misinformation uh so i don't
think it's more
uh complicated than that go ahead
uh let ebony go
brian thank you you get an internship or
something i don't know
um we will have four more minutes left
so we'll get to as many as we can
go ahead
with the vice president today most of
which have basically
said that they want the president to
really talk about uh the filibuster
moving it
or reforming the filibuster and so with
each of the meetings that they're having
i'm still coming out wondering
what is the hope that's going to happen
because just about every single woman
that is in that room has
spoken about that's my first my first
question is even though you also said
that there
isn't a plan right now for the president
to go to arizona or to go to other
states
why isn't there right now that kind of
plan because they have come out and said
that they put the administration just
put a lot on them but they're waiting to
see something
something that well i've laid out for
you what we know about our schedule
which is through next wednesday
so it doesn't mean that he's not going
to go out in the country and talk about
a range of important priorities
in the future and i don't want you to
take it that way that was not what i was
implying uh
but we're we're about we have about four
days out here
in our terms of our scheduling that i
can provide to all of you uh as it
relates to the
uh women who are in this room let's see
maybe they'll go to the stakeout and
they'll talk about their meeting and
their engagement and
the message that the president is
sending the vice president is sending is
that
we're absolutely committed to getting
the for the people act signed into law
that we're committed to advocating for
to elevating voting rights is an
important issue for people across this
country
and i think our actions clearly
exemplify that go ahead
clarifying question on how you identify
this misinformation
i'm wondering if you could tell us
specifically how the administration
identifies what is missing information
and then how you flag it to facebook
that's one
uh two is how many times has the
administration flagged this kind of
information um and then three how long
has this been going and then finally
i know that that you are deadly serious
about this conversation you talked about
how this is life and death
but are there any types of safeguards
that the administration is putting in
place to make certain that they do not
chill
free speech while they are going after
this kind of disinformation
first of all to be crystal clear any
decision about
uh platform usage and who should be on
the platform
is uh orchestrated and determined by
private sector companies
facebook is one of them right uh and
there are a range of media
who are also have their own criteria
and um rules in place and they implement
them
and that's their decision to do that is
not the federal government doing that
it is life and death it is a public
health
issue in the country that's why the
surgeon general was here
talking about it yesterday there are
trends
we can see any you can all probably see
on facebook and other social media
platforms
and so what we raise are issues like
there is a lot of information out there
about uh about in the the false
claim that covid19 causes infertility
everyone in this room knows that's
factually inaccurate we raise for them
in our direct channels of which every
administration has always had with every
social media platform
that we are seeing this trend it's
troubling that information's inaccurate
but specifically so
you're not going after you're saying
these are general areas of
misinformation you should take a look at
not specific posts yes it is also
publicly available
who the individuals are who have who
have spread
most of the information wasn't publicly
available by the united states
government it's publicly available
information
so that's how it works okay thank you
everyone i've got
to wrap it up i'm sorry have a great
okay brian
go ahead last one very quick on
afghanistan though we're not
engaged
too okay
you